miles de personas marchan en el centro
de la ciudad de buenos aires- en esta
protesta convocada por organizaciones
sociales no alineadas con el gobierno
nacional
estas organizaciones sociales al igual
que las que son cercanas al gobierno del
presidente alberto fernández tienen
entre sus tareas la de distribuir los
planes sociales que entrega el estado
nacional algo que es especialmente clave
e importante en un país con una pobreza
que alcanza el 40 por ciento de la
población en esta marcha entre otras
cosas lo que están reclamando es más
fondos para estos planes sociales y
también están mirando a un posible
acuerdo con el fondo monetario
internacional con la desconfianza de que
ese acuerdo lleve a un ajuste un recorte
en las partidas de los planes sociales
esta marcha que también se realiza en
otras partes del país es una especie de
convocatoria previa a una más grande que
se espera para el 11 y 12 de marzo
cuando también se espera que jacques se
conozcan los detalles de un eventual
acuerdo con el fondo monetario y se sepa
o no va a tocar especialmente las
partidas vinculadas con los planes
sociales